hey guys in this mkbhd video we'll be
taking a look at the editors keys sl150
studio USB microphone the microphone
ergo kind of here is actually on a stand
the samson m.d. file which i in box
earlier on this channel but we were
looking at here is a microphone that i
record all my videos with both
screencasts and hardware videos when i
do voiceovers including this video here
the form factor this microphone as with
most other USB microphones is pretty
compact so you're actually going to be
able to go portable with this in fact it
does come with a leather carrying case
which i haven't actually found the need
to use yet but just in case you go
portable with your mics you have that
option now keep in mind that there are
some other USB studio quality
microphones
unlike the SL 150 that are really big
and weigh a lot and actually come with
their own stand for example the blue
yeti this is something you won't be
going mobile with a lot but the SL 150
is very durable and very very usable for
anyone who likes to bring the mic around
also worth noting is the construction of
the microphone itself and from top to
bottom it seems to be made of a nice
light aluminum some sort of metal at the
top but as you get down to the body it's
actually made of a rigid hard plastic so
keep in mind that you're actually gonna
want to use the case if you're going
portable don't just throw it in your
backpack actually use a case but when
it's sitting on your desk just for
recording it's a really high-quality
microphone and you're probably not going
to notice what it's made of anyway as a
matter of fact when i sit this
microphone on my desk to do audio
recordings like i am doing right now i
actually just pop it right in the stand
and adjust it to the height and just
plug and play it's that simple this
microphone requires no drivers it's just
USB 2.0 plugging into your computer
comes with a really long USB cable and
that's really it so it's a really simple
mic if you've never used a high level
microphone or this is definitely a good
intro level microphone now i can't talk
about this microphone without reviewing
its quality and i gotta say it's the
highest quality USB studio microphone on
the market for under a hundred and fifty
dollars in the united states behind this
mesh is a gold diaphragm condenser of 22
millimeters with a frequency response
pickup of 20 to 18 thousand kilohertz
that's way more than the human vocals
and it's a hyper-cardioid patterned
microphone so that's really all you're
going to be picking up is that one voice
so this is perfect for your home or
studio podcasting you know if you're
still not convinced that the audio
quality of this microphone without
listening to me speak to you through it
you can
check out my audio test of the
microphone that I recorded not too long
ago versus a gooseneck voice over IP mic
which was also a pretty high-end
microphone and you'll see the difference
ah you'll hear the difference overall if
I didn't make it clear earlier this
microphone and stand combination with
the Samson MD 5 really makes it easy to
just pull the mic over to the front of
the desk and start recording a video
it really is adds to the convenience
factor as it doesn't come with this
stand so wrap it all up I've got some
pros and cons for the microphone some
pros are that it has great audio quality
for the price has pretty solid builds
construction looks really good it even
glows when it's plugged in and it's a
plug and play mic with a really long USB
cord easy to set up the things I didn't
like about it or that it didn't come
with a stand and also that it didn't
come with any sort of pop filter which I
actually do utilise to record with this
mic with that set of pros and cons I can
give this microphone a rating of eight
and a half out of ten I think editor's
keys can do a lot better in a couple of
certain areas about this mic but overall
it's a very very good value recording
studio microphone I'm also looking
forward to possibly reviewing the
editors Keys SL 600 in the near future
so stay tuned for that anyway thanks for
watching this mkbhd review video and
i'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace